what's up guys first and foremost thanks
for watching daily vlog the speed and
intensity of this is gonna be fun
anyway keeping an eye on this episode
make sure you pay attention to you know
when to let go not to try to control
everything recognizing how much control
you do have and also recognizing when to
let go of control what I mean by that as
you'll see in the London all hands on
meeting I don't need the London's office
to act the way LA's office acts like the
way New York's office acts so many CEOs
and leaders try to do that I think it's
a huge mistake
I think you need to let the leaders
within those organizations do their
thing and then just the thematics of
everything which is I just think way too
many people are paying attention to
macro trends and think that politics or
leaders or organizations or platforms of
websites or other human beings control
their outcome you control your [ __ ] now
watch this
so I just landed in London us and just
saw the election news you know just my
two cents so many people are heading me
up so just something to point to when
when I get the emails or the questions I
was born in Soviet Russia and I love
Vera I love America very very much and
my true belief is that you know I have
lots of texts from friends that are
scared and very worried and texts from
friends who are elated an optimistic end
you know this is what always happens in
America were very much divided on a lot
of fiscal and social issues and so I
just want to remind everybody that
unlike Soviet Russia we have so much
more control you know some will say
that's slipping away and I understand
where everybody's coming from but my
family I'm on the offense I don't
believe any man or woman as the
president United States is gonna dig
down dictate the outcome of my life and
so I will always fight to love everybody
team human not just us something I'm
very passionate about and and I will
fight for meritocracy and in capitalism
because I believe it in so I just hope
that everybody takes a step back and
realizes I'm not pissed I'm just an and
so we're gonna fight
fight for our families and be in full
control as we really are
the hospital I have to get me to that
Senior Center on Monday about getting
the boat you wanna tell me so I went to
choose one
in shape
just like entry the
one thing before I forget 5:30
hey ru how's it going Harry do we have a
course even in times were uncertainty or
or things of that nature I am just
incapable of not being optimistic one of
the things that I've always prided
Vayner in and my life in is just work
ethic and and kind of the stomach for
adversity and so anybody I mean you
don't ask a veiner question anybody want
to talk about the market or you know
like like meeting the market as in like
snapchat or you know yeah you ever can I
talked a little bit about that so since
you brought it up like look I think one
of the great advantages is being quiet
I'm loud but veiners quiet right and
that has been very much something that I
think has benefitted us as such a fast
growing company I'm not worried about
you telling some secret there's no
secret I there's nothing we're doing
that's so secret I think that we're
gonna win and I think that when you're
gonna win something and tear down the
establishment you have to have some
equal balance of humility to the
marketplace because I'm surely not doing
that I'm going to a an A in front of the
entire market and telling them that
they're [ __ ] faces and we're gonna
kill them
so I need the machine to kind of have
that left like the level of pride I have
that this is an actual steak that
complements the sizzle that I put out
into the world really matters oh you
want some sorry I thought I gave you the
first one I thought you had it okay let
me let me pour it for you here you go
you're welcome
got it yes I wasn't thinking red white
dynamic song
shame on me so what's ironic is I think
that the studio which is in our old
office a couple blocks from Vayner feels
like a million miles away - truth is
that's why I believe so much in you guys
like like that dream of it feels the
same as the same way of laddering up
creative to the same pillar it's not
real it's not real but that doesn't mean
it's wrong I genuinely think of it as
like the United States of America which
is I feel like New York is DC or at
least my office is DC and I believe that
this is you know Texas and Eric is the
governor I think this aspiration of
making it feel they Toby's evolving New
York doesn't feel like the New York that
you guys worked in like you're not the
same when you're four and seven I have a
4 and a 7 year old they're different
like you know like and that's okay
people that get mad about a tactic start
saying we've changed or I don't believe
like if you love your mother she may do
something you don't like but that
doesn't mean you don't love your mother
anymore right and so I want I want it to
always live and breathe it always well
London doesn't feel like London - the
first seven people and it's definitely
not gonna feel like London in the next
three months four months when this is
double the size like some of you are
gonna make jokes of like I've been here
for five months and I'm a veteran right
like that's
that's that's the game right I mean
right like like that's what it is
so so here this is why I'm drilling the
honey Empire thing over and over and I
will be drilling it more there's only
two things I care about that we are the
kindest to each other ever in this game
and that we don't let that come at the
expense of being very good at your craft
just well beyond the last time you hear
that it a few people win at optimism
because you have to be so much better
it's a very interesting thing I know you
get it cool right again it's hard
that's why nobody sells what I sell
it's so hard
can we get a picture of you the funny
thing is always watching your videos
2008 when you said the house of cards
like these crazy
because I know it's the only option you
have to switch your mind to thinking
it's a negative I thought it was a
positive you're empathetic to where he's
coming from I get it that's why I'm not
good at being an assistant or immunity
manager now you understand it here for
you that's fine fine really hope you can
leave me everyday anymore
where we go where am I going yeah let me
see if this I feel like this person
wants to say hello
hey thank you actually I was stunning
here didn't know what to say don't worry
I saw you hovering what's your name
Oh Montes Montessori yeah very nice man
I'm actually like right now I'm setting
the business and I'm doing market thing
I'm working on a start-up bean market
again right now starting your company as
well good for you man good luck the
thing is we're doing like we found with
a friend we're doing this kind of
advertising through Instagram and now
it's a very complex structure now we're
looking for it like the tax authority we
don't know how well send me an email to
Gary or vaynermedia I'll send you some
people that can help you I'm dead
serious
Oh Gary at vaynermedia I'll try to hook
you up
take care
let's make positivity louder easy doing
it none of what do you know no no no
that's the punchline it's one brick it's
one brick at a time actually believing
it no no actually believing it yeah my
content is pretty happy and I'm a happy
dude and what's that do you know what's
funny no negativity is a lot easier to
sell that's why it's working like what I
do for a living is much harder I'm
trying to win on positivity which is the
hardest sell first of all they're wrong
you're either you're either you're
either on offense or you're not like to
me dwelling is super not interesting
it's got zero value I just buy dope you
need to be thoughtful you need to
understand you need to not have too much
ego to lack the humility that why did we
get here
but dwelling I'm not interested in
dwelling of what just happened in our
countries I'm willing to like I'm
interested in like being on the offense
to a start closing the gap back to the
social I care about the social impacts
it really work I sent an email to the
entire company tonight of an emoji heart
knows it or not I think I wrote
something like I love you or something
but the emails that I got back we're so
insane like just like people like really
needed it like people like it so it
takes so little to do so like it's so
easy to say hey like or wink at somebody
or just smile but it's not because you
actually have to believe it and people
don't actually believe it this is
negative like I want to be on the
offense of positivity not dwell and to
understand how we got here
1:02 in the morning London good
productive day just nice 45 minute with
my homies Sean and it's time to get a
time to get some sleep all right Sean
see you later